after millions of americans crossed the
country and gathered over the holidays
health experts are warning of another
surge
on top of a surge as we get into the
next few weeks it might actually get
worse
adding to those concerns the spread of a
new more contagious variant of the virus
after appearing in the uk last week it's
been found in several countries
including france australia japan and now
canada experts believe the strain is
likely already here in the u.s but dr
fauci says public health officials
worldwide are monitoring the situation
does it make someone more ill is it more
serious
virus in the sense of virulence and the
answer is it doesn't appear to be that
way
the numbers in the u.s are already
staggering
roughly 200 000 new cases daily
nearly 120 000 people currently
hospitalized
and more than 2 000 people dying every
single day yet there
are still people ignoring public health
rules in beverly hills california the
famous la scala restaurant was reported
to authorities by its own customers
after giving out invitations to a secret
indoor new year's eve party
the invitation said in part welcome back
to the 20's prohibition
the restaurant didn't respond to a
request for comment
city officials say they've contacted
management
it's frustrating to front-line health
care workers like dr vanessa
walker who says california's beleaguered
hospitals
may not be able to handle an even bigger
surge in the coming weeks
it feels like we are working hard every
day trying to save lives
and it's just falling on deaf ears we
will take care of you we'll find places
we'll put you in hallways we'll put you
in conference rooms
but ask yourself is a bed in a
conference room as good as the bed in a
regular patient room
i don't think so